日本の歯医者
第三章
部屋に入ると
思わずため息が出る。
Appleの製品紹介動画が作れるんじゃないかと思うぐらい、真っ白で清潔な部屋。
最新のマッサージチェア、
というよりＪＡＬのファーストクラスのスカイスリーパーみたいな椅子が四つ並んでいて、
それぞれの右手に、風洞を使ってデザインしたような美しい流線型の電気スタンドが立っている。
天井には待合室と同じような「BRAVIAどこでも窓」がかかっていて、
その中では、YUKIさんが今度はマチュピチュの階段を登っている。
音量は小さく、音質がはっきりしていて、
彼女の言葉は聞こうと思えば簡単に聞き取れるし、
また無視しようと思えばできるので、
思考の邪魔にはならない。
部屋の左の壁には自動水栓がいくつかついている。
その手前には、キャスターのついた、洗濯機と同じくらい大きな白い立方体の機械が二つ置いてある。
近代的な冷蔵庫？
未来の加湿器？
どちらにも見えるので、僕はトランスフォーマーだと思うことにした。
再びシリア。
最初に目についたのは
拷問道具の山だ。
部屋の中央には残りつぶした三菱ミニカから放り出された椅子…
みたいなもの一つあって、
その右手には大きな雑巾を被せたテーブルが置いてあり、
その上には、
拷問道具のフルーツ・バスケット。
針。
メス。
細長い鋸の歯。
釣り針のついたボールペン。
１５センチはありそうな注射器。
「酸」とか「ガス」とか書いてある容器。
ペンチに
ペンチにペンチに
ペンチにペンチにペンチに
ペンチにペンチにペンチにペンチに
ペンチにペンチにペンチにペンチにペンチに
怖くなって視線を天井に向けると、
「頑張れ」とか
「忍耐は美徳だ」とか書いてあるポスターが貼ってある。
視線を落とすと、
今度は椅子の肘掛けの先に誰かの指の形が残っていることに気づき、
一段と猛烈な恐怖に襲われる。